dana might want to release one of these
guys not release but allow one of these
fighters because remember anybody signed
to the ufc cannot fight a paul brother
unless dana says it's okay even if
they're retired
george st pierre can't fight without
dana's blessing because he's still under
contract that's why he couldn't fight
oscar de la hoya oh i didn't know that
so he got them signed i mean he got them
on a deal
so i wonder for the brand if you just
let one of the bad boys out there if you
let a jorge mas vidal someone with
[ __ ] hands yo go take care of this
whole problem for me
if you let nate diaz go yo take care of
this little problem that's the only way
say what you can't risk that because
what if one of your big dogs [ __ ]
goes down to them
and they might so that's why you can't
risk that uh he's playing it he's
playing it the way he's supposed to play
but he's gonna keep on driving that
[ __ ] thorn into his side yeah
everything jake is gonna keep on now
jake has a legit win i mean ben askren
was an incredibly effective fighter but
everyone knew he's not strong he was
exactly his hands were he was doughy his
hands were salt like nothing about him
as a boxer nothing about him look like
he looked like an athlete yeah
and he is an athlete and he was a
puncher and an elite ufc striker just
gets demolished by a disney star i'll
repeat that an elite ufc striker gets
demolished by a disney star bad for the
[ __ ] brand
yeah i didn't think he i didn't know he
was considered an elite streak that's
his biggest payday ever
and
then ufc striker gets his biggest payday
ever and gets demolished by a disney
star yeah i mean just pieced up i didn't
think he was gonna win i didn't know
he's considered elite and i was just
thinking like this is an mma guy he
hasn't trained in boxing think what you
will about fighting it's different but
and i found myself i was rooting for
woodley for the fight but at the end of
the fight after jake paul won i was like
yo why do we hate this guy
and we should all appreciate this moment
like we all we all think about i'm sure
back in the day like celebrity boxing be
kind of cool just seeing these guys beat
the [ __ ] out of each other but none of
them can fight now you got a celebrity
who can fight and is taken out granted
it's not their sport but he's taking out
mma guys in a fight sport
this is kind of [ __ ] cool because i
don't think jake paul has that many wins
left in him i think as he steps up this
fight proved to me like i think a real
boxer i think i think you're [ __ ] but
this is the genius of this fight
now he has one more fight to make the
100 mil yes and it's over now he claims
he made 100 mil in this fight i don't
know if that's true but he said i'm 10
closer to being a billionaire now
that means 100 million right 10 billion
100 million maybe he may have made it in
i'm not really trying to count pockets
he definitely made a lot of [ __ ]
money there's no question right
got the lion share that pay-per-view
paid everybody out lovely that being
said
he
by taking this risk and it was a risk to
fight woodley they knew it wasn't that
big a risk because they've been sparring
all these guys they've been bringing in
the mma guys he's been in the gym
fighting with these guys going wow it's
actually not that tough to fight them
and then fighting with real boxers and
going oh this is a different game yeah
he took mike perry you remember that
like he was born with my pair and he was
like oh i see what we're dealing with i
know a guy a guy that i train with
um in in miami mm-hmm
is one of his uh like coaches last
sparring partners i think uh either
coach sparring partner jake boswick he
was a bare knuckle guy and this guy was
a [ __ ] savage dude i remember just
being in the in the ring with him like
going man if you were coming at me
like with gloves on even not having fun
it would be a horrible day yeah yeah
just solid rock [ __ ] solid right so
if jake's in there banging away with
that guy
and he's banging away with these top
guys he's banging away with guys that
are legit boxers
and then he's getting there with these
mma guys and going this is a lot easier
he's when he called out kumaru yeah he
knew something yeah i i thought it was
all cap i thought i was like yo let me
just call out the biggest guy no
he knows in a straight
ham's boxing match he might have an
advantage on come on now if it's a mma
fight forget it you're looking at an
absolute [ __ ] sack they'll break his
limbs yeah ben asked him to break his
limbs yeah it don't matter like like
asking said i could commit a homicide if
i wanted and jake is aware of that i
don't think he'd ever say nah these
[ __ ] couldn't get me yeah but
in the boxing ring specifically you see
the limited tools you saw what happened
to connor against floyd and floyd's the
greatest ever connor's got one hand yeah
tyron has one hand it wasn't even close
like i told you my mind i was like oh
it'll be close it wasn't even close
wasn't even close yeah i oh you also got
to give jay credit i again i'm rooting
for woodley when i'm watching that
[ __ ] fourth round shot
jake came back from that he ate that and
he kept boxing you later
kid dawg this kid worth eight nine
figures whatever the [ __ ] it is and he
he takes that shot nothing really no
financial gain on the line and he's like
nah let's go let's keep boxing mm-hmm
yeah and i also think a lot of credit's
got to go to like his team like jake's
trainers and [ __ ] yeah i'm jay flores
like all those
like all those guys like i think i
almost think that yeah
yeah yeah their future is like oh yeah i
took jake paul and made him a star like
they could train anyone like i feel like
people would be wanting to get on that
team because they're like yo you took a
disney kid and made them into this yeah
even if it was jake paul's like work
ethic and everything else like for them
it looks great and on top of the fact
that they knew the fighters to go for
yeah like that requires a lot of
confidence yeah that's savvy dude you
can't the kid might act like he's not
the brightest or whatever
he's not dumb he's sharp but the team
too like that they can look at tyrant
and go oh yeah you like this guy's got
hands he has the resume but he's not
gonna go for it and let go in the final
rounds and you could actually take it
yeah like to know that ahead of time is
like crazy fight iq yeah no they know
what they're doing and give a credit to
him because i don't know anybody that's
bj is trained outside of jake bj flores
is his head trainer
so i don't know i knew he was a boxer
back in the day but i don't know where
else he's trained to just understand
that to see these guys in the gym and
like see the sparring and expose that
weakness in mma is it's impressive and
i'm telling you the biggest payday he's
the biggest opponent in boxing opponent
are you taking floyd out of that
floyd's retired in my opinion okay and
but if he comes back for like a money
fight with someone like whether it's
logan or whether it's canelo whoever it
is like would that be a bigger payday
way bigger well but i don't look at
floyd as an opponent
floyd is the boxer
floyd is the name
jake is the opponent like canelo's the
name
jake is the opponent that's why that's
why he said canelo's biggest opponent
he's the bee's opponent in boxing okay
right so if you look at like the the
real quote-unquote real box he's a real
boxer now but look at the legacy boxes
the guys who exist right now champions
the champions that are out there their
biggest opponent is not someone else in
their division some cuban guy you guys
can't even pronounce his [ __ ] name
but it's gonna be jake paul and it
doesn't matter who it is [ __ ] keith
thurman your biggest payday
jake paul fema lopez your biggest payday
jake paul like it don't matter who it is
jamante davis your biggest payday jake
paul
i get it does that make sense now okay
so it's like all those guys could fight
each other and make less money if they
fought jake and jake put himself in that
position with this win over tyron and
that's why connor who wouldn't even
mention his name is all sudden going
salivating
and of course he would like a boxing
match because i know you don't want to
do any kicking anytime soon yeah the
best thing that conor could have for his
comeback is to go [ __ ] up jake paul make
100 million in the process but i'll tell
you one thing it ain't gonna be easy
yeah it ain't gonna be easy i'm not
positive i i i think i would have bet
jake this fight i think i would bet
conor if they fought but i wouldn't be
super confident look conor had power to
145 comes up to 155 nope not really have
power no 170 no power just speed
190 what do you have yeah what do you
have at five seven 190 going up against
a guy who's six feet legit power right
yeah i didn't even yeah yeah yeah
right yeah easily yeah
yeah so i'm almost like i don't know if
conor takes that fight
like legacy wise he's like i just lost
to dustin
do i really want this
i mean it's just how much is 150 ml to
me now he made 180 last year do you want
another 150 and also if you're dana it's
like do i want my cash cow
to get concussed by a disney star
it's the worst so after this i'm like i
don't know if we even see that fight of
course i mean of course not maybe the
al's point it's like now you can't let
any of them play it's just too big a
risk
the question is who in mma and the
problem if you don't let any of them you
if any of them fight jake just keeps
[ __ ] talking that [ __ ] and not just
talking that [ __ ] he's talking to the
fighters like yo why won't dana let you
get your payday breach contract and that
[ __ ] with you more than you losing in
the brand as a fighter personally like
this [ __ ] really not letting me
make eight figures on a fight he's gonna
pay me six figures you want to fight
charles oliveira for 250 grand or you
want to fight jake paul for 10 million
if he goes yo a break contract i'll pay
for it that's a crazy flex i don't know
what the actual money is for breaching
contract like that but i mean you're
going to be tied up in litigation
forever you're never going to see any of
that [ __ ] money they might even stop
the fight like that they might have
legal recourse to not allow the fight
you don't have to go that far just keep
[ __ ] with these guys because i even
if it's a sanctioning body like the if
you're going through an actual sanction
like the nevada like athletic commission
would be like yeah but even if that
doesn't have remember francis and ghana
was on our podcast and he was like
something about the money he didn't seem
very upset about money then after the
first jake paul been asking fight he
tweeted something like how the [ __ ] are
these guys making so much money they're
all noticing and jay paul is calling it
out so they're noticing even more like
yo this is the payday so dana almost if
you don't let these guys if you cut it
all off they're all gonna start looking
like why are you cutting off
the biggest payday in my life on a sport
where i risk my life yeah for a quarter
of the damage mind you also yeah like
you get in the ring with jake paul
you're like all right i'm going to walk
home you know
i lose my split decision and i make 10
million
yeah or what he wants to remember
retiring not making no 10 million
dollars
no he made more than he made before i
think yeah maybe he made a mill or
something like that but like
still it's still better than you're ever
gonna make anything in in ufc yeah it's
just unbelievably impressive to see what
happened with this fight he can call out
whoever he wants now and you have to
take it seriously and again i think we
should enjoy this whether you like him i
hate him either way just enjoy what's
happening because the second he starts
fighting real boxes i think it's a rap
and if i'm him
i'm not fighting him yeah like why fight
him you know
you fight one real boxer for a hundred
million dollar penny that's the only
thing that you do you fight canelo you
fight tyson [ __ ] fury it doesn't
matter if you get knocked out in the
first round make the big money tyson
will kill him yeah maybe the heavyweight
thing is a little bit yeah give him some
advantage how far is floyd
deonte wilder would [ __ ]
how far is floyd what like is that even
an option you think is that even a fight
like
i think after floyd went in there with
logan and he was like man i can't hurt
these guys yeah it's not funny he's not
just too far weight class like yeah
he'll beat him the same way that he'd be
located it'd just be basically the same
flight yeah and it's like okay they can
take a punch like tyrant hit him with a
great shot yeah he stood up and he kept
swinging the rest of the round
like this is tyrant hits hard he's got a
chin yeah especially with those big
gloves they're tough yeah the kids are
tough so it's like i don't even know if
floyd cares about all that especially if
his team's like yo jake's actually maybe
a little more technical might be better
than than logan yeah so yeah i i just um
bro
i don't know al you're not buying it why
not just because it was ugly boxing bro
yeah it was ugly boxing like i've never
seen boxing that ugly this is what i
that's he's not a pro boxer i'm watching
this i'm like oh i see how you're a real
boxer we'll [ __ ] you up but an about mma
box there's also nothing
and the drama is there enough that we
know we gotta talk about it i get the
entertainment factor about it and i'm
not a hater on that but just it okay
here's the thing there are mistakes that
he that he's making uh not mistakes per
se but just like things that he's doing
sometimes off balance he'll throw a
double jab and his back foot will like
slide out the back like like just
different weird things that happen
because he's young in the game
but here's the biggest uh equalizer
power
like if you look at guys who have power
like real power a lot of times the
technique ain't [ __ ]